somebody who i've known for a very long
time he was there the first minute i
walked in the door
uh with the espn and he is still there
he is none other than chris mortensen
how are you mort
rich i'm doing well how are you how's
susie and the kids
now susie is great she sends her best to
you more she really does
you're one of the best brother well how
are you feeling let's start with that
you're good well i'm i'm feeling okay i
actually had my scans
on this day that we're talking right now
i had my uh some some more scans
uh uh now into my starting my sixth year
of this cancer journey so
listen um it's 20 21 i'm still alive
this has been a journey and i've got now
wait for the scans everybody gets
anxious about those
sure i'm not as anxious got a little
uh side effect reaction to the iodine
they put in me but
you know you're going to have heritage
junior on right sir yes sir
you know extremely talented individual
and i i just had to
go this out there just chris my wife and
i watched copycat last night
i was making that watch copycats yes
copycat starts the gorny weaver made in
1995
but it's when i realized harry connick
jr i've already known has always had
a lot of talent but he's really a
great a great psycho loon in copycat
and i just happened to watch it last
night well i will pass that along mort
uh i will pass that along to him when he
joins because he is multi-talented and
he's a
he's a die-hard saints fan to say the
least what are you hearing about drew
brees right now let's get right into the
football conversation
um uh peter king our colleague uh
said yesterday he was told by someone
who he trusts uh
pay no attention to the fact that he has
yet to announce his retirement but now
we're getting into the
the part of uh of the nfl calendar where
there's a lot of news breaking and and
if i want to retire and i i
you know and i'd like to have a little
bit of the spotlight by myself and
there's no reason why he wouldn't want
to do that or you would begrudge him
that
don't you think he should have said
something by now more what are you
hearing
uh i know when it comes to those type of
things like
retirement i think they gotta be able to
do on their terms when it feels right
that
you know they want to have that
announcement uh i haven't heard that he
is he is
you know truly contemplating a comeback
but uh yeah it's a little odd that it's
gone this far usually it's you know
within a month the guys like to take
about 30 days and
then uh go ahead and make that decision
but once you make it you know
the old saying but once you retire you
you know once you say you're retired or
contemplating retirement then you're
retired uh now
uh obviously kyle long of the bears was
actually coming out of three-year
retirement or whatever it is a couple of
years retirement
doesn't know that but drew brees here's
the thing i
i think that drew and sean payton the
coach of the saints
they've had their conversations i think
sean has dropped all the hints
includes he wants with with trying to be
respectful to drew that drew
drew is headed into uh lower broadcast
land
uh as we as we know and if if he
is full of shocker said i'm not going to
retire
next question i would have is is this
going to be with the saints
and and that that's the question i would
have i i think the saints are probably
prepared to move on and maybe and we're
prepared to move on a year ago
but obviously when you came back like
okay you know
let's go we'll go no another round but
uh i think the saints are ready to move
on
chris mortensen here on the rich eisen
show um
before we get to your report on the
eagles uh yesterday that made a lot of
news
what do you make of dak prescott signing
for this figure um
and whether you know jerry jones waited
too long or there's been a lot of
criticism about that but i don't think
he cares
if dak wins him a championship that's
that's what he wants right now what
what do you make of this signing mort
i've always maintained that uh and just
listen i
haven't known jerry since he bought the
cowboys listen
when jerry tells you something
especially privately you can take it to
the bank literally in this case
either take it to the bank or you take
the money out of the bank
but he's always made it clear to me that
dec
was going nowhere this contract would
get done
they got close last year it was over the
uh length
length of the contract four years is
what dak wanted five years is what jerry
and the cowboys wanted
and actually if you think about it if
you count the franchise year
last year where he made just under 32
million dollars on the franchise tag
and you add the four years that are
really going to count on this one
uh that's the five years that the
cowboys wanted since that
you know rookie contract expired so it's
a five-year deal
but that gained four million dollars per
year by waiting
because because uh if you average that
31.7 million whatever it was he made a
franchise tag
compared to what he's making the average
of this five-year total
it's going to be around 38.5 million
dollars so i guess what i'm saying is
when i talk to jerry jones last thursday
night but didn't tell anybody
except i went on a sportscenter draft
special uh
todd mcshays i just said i'll say this
he is going to be part of the immediate
and future uh at quarterback for the
dallas cowboys
so i'm not surprised i think it's great
money for dak
i think he's earned it you know the guy
the guy in his first four years
as a fourth round pick got 3.3 million
dollars
total and they got pro bowl caliber
quarterbacking so i think jerry's also
gotten his value out of dak prescott so
i i think this is a great thing for
for both sides chris mortensen here on
the rich eisen show let's get to the
philadelphia eagles situation
what is going on in philadelphia what
what
what because a lot of this doesn't
square
to to have went stay at the starter as
long as he did but
you know uh our friend your colleague
currently at espn my old colleague at
nfl network adam schefter saying that
doug peterson and wence didn't talk for
quite some time and yet
he was holding the wence line for what i
appeared to from my perspective way too
long
they go to hertz and then pull him in
the fourth quarter of game 256
then peterson loses his job they then
hand over the reins to somebody who's
never done it before nick ciriani and
now
your report saying that jeff laurie
doesn't want a quarterback competition
he wants hurts so then why wouldn't
hertz be the perfect quarterback for
doug peterson to be
in as opposed to somebody who's never
done it before i'll give you the floor
with that preamble as the setup
more yeah i think there's a there's a
lot there and and
sometimes it's easy to misread the cards
uh and and i can understand that you
know i i reported it and knew that the
relationship between
doug peterson and once was fractured
and how it got there we don't have
enough time
uh and i think part of that is that as
carson
got deeper into being an experienced
quarterback he wanted more control
more control of what you did at the line
of scrimmage expand the offense
wanted more input whereas i think doug
you know wanting to maintain that
and simplify some things because of
injuries or whatever and it eventually
it just didn't work i mean
you know that was a disaster last year
for the eagles their offensive line was
a disaster
i think what it proves and a couple is
that yes it's a team game and what's
crumbled with it now hurts when he was
taken in the second round last year
it surprised people and and it really
was about carson wentz's injury history
not his performance but the fact is is
that the the january before in that
playoff game against seattle when jv and
county
nailed went from the back of the head
and gave him that concussion
the eagles are saying wow it's another
year we we you know
we're we're not finishing the season
with carson wentz as their quarterback
they bought that insurance and jalen
hurts and then we saw what happened with
once in terms of how bad it was
larry listen the one thing he he said
and i
i believed him reported about it before
he said it
which is that you know
doug peterson status coach was not going
to be tired to carson west
that gets us to your jalen hurts
question uh
jeffrey laurie said after he fired
peterson that he wants a more forward
long-term vision of with this franchise
and
the sense i got was that doug having won
a super bowl
you know it was like you know let's
let's let's get going and then uh
find a way to win this year uh and uh
hurts is a guy that i think is that they
want to fight jeffrey larry wants to
find out if he
is the guy in other words we have the
sixth pick of the draft
you're right that last game was bizarre
we had a six pick in the draft
uh i don't want to get another
quarterback to see
if we've got the guy i want to find out
if hertz is a guy so
you my personnel staff howie roseman and
all the guys in the personal apartment
you guys build this team to see if we
can make jalen hurt successful
and see if we got what we have in him
before we move on to the
to whether he you know if he isn't then
we'll move on to the next guy
so he confused you no no no you didn't
no you didn't morta
i'm just trying to you know so the
question i have out of everything you
just
mentioned there if you could shed some
light on it
is that for peterson to say i want to
win now
and if that wasn't hurts then it would
have been based on the quarterbacks that
they had there
once and their relationship was
fractured
and you know you see what i'm saying
like it just doesn't
make much sense look i think hertz is
the answer i think hertz is i think
hurts
is all that i i i i would i would build
with him
for sure but if he is wanting a more
long-term answer
and is the rest of the building on board
with that obviously they have to be if
he's the
owner uh but man top of the photo well
yeah listen
the owner people well uh jeffrey larry
you know a lot of people say well this
sounds like jerry jones listen
when it comes to the quarterback and and
the long-term vision of a franchise the
owner
is almost always involved i mean
they may not be out there talking as
much but uh and they should be involved
in terms of
setting the vision for the franchise now
doug peterson
i think there were a lot of layers to
that it wasn't just a you know he didn't
get fired because
his fractured relationship with carson
wentz but there was
constant uh internal battle
over his coaching staff once frank
wright left for the indianapolis colts
and we can blame josh mcdaniels for that
as you know
uh when he backed out of that coast job
i think once
frank wright left doug had you know
a challenge to put together the right
staff for for what they had
on offense uh not just with carson once
but the rest of it
and when he wanted to change steps he's
forced to change some staff members and
he didn't want to change this year
jeffrey leary didn't like that so a lot
of that was about
jeffrey larry losing faith in doug
peterson's uh
to build the proper coaching staff now
that can be debated and argued all kinds
of
ways because the guy won a super bowl
didn't he yeah doug did uh
so it you know it's certainly the head
scratcher for a lot of people but
uh you know i think doug was tired of of
being told
that he couldn't hire certain guys that
he wanted to hire for his staff
so i think the eagles are jalen hurts
yeah i mean i mentioned clj with i know
jaylen personally
uh you know i like jalen but you know i
also know carson once was a heck of a
talent as well
but i know what from what i know jeffrey
larry just says
let's let's find out about hurt as
opposed to taking a quarterback with a
sixth pick
i watched him go and take one i'm just
kidding uh
let's let's pick let's take this draft
and this off season
rebuild our offense uh around jalen and
see what we can do with him
and see if he is the answer quarterback
because they you can't keep drafting a
quarterback
in the first and second round every year
yes you can drop the quarterback every
year
but not in the first and second round so
then last one for you chris
on the couple minutes i have left here
what do you think jeffrey luery would be
more gun shy about
based on what happened with wence
trading up to the second overall spot to
take a shot on zach wilson or
uh re-signing uh or or
giving a long-term deal to whichever
quarterback is the
future of the team and hertz or wilson
or whomever
uh early based on what we just saw what
happened with wence
what's more what what do you think he's
more gun shy with here
yeah well you know the west contract uh
it may make him a little gun shy but i i
to be honest with you he really studied
i mean there's
there's an ability to get out of the
contract early
uh but you're going to take your cap hit
i think well you can't you can't
give a guy a long-term contractor out
this third year i think he would be more
nervous about that with jaylen earth but
remember jalen hurst
it's kind of like a dak prescott
situation you know deck was a fourth
round and jalen second-rounder
doesn't have that fifth year option so
the contracts for four years that's
different than wentz and goff
trading up to the number two spot from
number six i don't
think he has any desire to do that and i
also don't think it's going to be
available i think zach wilson is it's
i think it's the jets i think he's the
jets quarterback it's his job to lose is
the praise i
even though there's no finality in that
but uh i think that zach wilson is going
to be the second
pick on this draft and it's going to be
the jets and i do not
think that the eagles or jeffrey larry
have any desire to go trade up into the
two spot for zach wilson
chris you're the man you be well i hope
you get back the uh the scan
uh reports that we're all hoping for and
uh
let's chat uh let's chat before the
draft let's chat in a couple weeks
yeah and you'll be well too i'm a little
uh
oh you know daniel jerry might have
tried to take away your 40-yard dash but
we're holding it we're holding it to you
[ __ ] on this one we're holding it to
you yeah i will
and i will do it next month no matter
what dj and i'm going to make him time
it for
certainly because of what he had to say
about the 40-yard uh
dash no longer i guess going by the way
the dodo bird but thanks for the call
chris you take care
be well be well my you got it mort
report on twitter i follow him you
should too
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here